GTA 6 soll erst 2025 rauskommen keine
Ahnung warum die jetzt schon Trailer
ausgehauen haben ich will jetzt aber
auch nicht der 7 milliard Youtuber sein
der darauf reagiert von daher habe ich
mir ein paar Fragen
gestellt die Gerüchte Küche brodelt ja
wir auch für die Switch rauskommen
stimmt dieser Map liag der auf Reddit so
zahlreich geteilt wurde wirklich darüber
wird diskutiert die ganze Grafik wird
hops genommen im Internet kann das
wirklich sein dass das Spiel so eine
krasse Realitätsnähe bekommt jedoch ist
das allerkrasseste was sich in den
letzten Tagen die meisten Leute gefragt
haben ob man in GTA 6 auch mit ganz
normalen
NPCs reden kann klar man kann die in GTA
V überfahren und dann beleidigen die ein
oder schlagen auf dich drauf aber kann
man mit ihnen wirklich interagieren und
genau davon handelt Replika was in der
Community als GTA 6 Demo bezeichnet wird
das hier ist das Spiel ihr seht schon
wir befinden uns in New York die
Grafik also die Grafik ist geistskrank
um Längen besser als GTA V gerade wenn
man sich so Details anguckt wie hier
beispielsweise die wasserfüzen auf dem
Boden die Autos wie die gemodelt sind
hier vorne das ist z.B ein alter Porsche
glaube ich also klar die haben jetzt
logischerweise keine Recht an den Marken
aber es sieht schon krass aus und ihr
seht schon hier rechts hold down se to
talk what lauf mal weiter in dem Bereich
den ich noch nicht freigeschaltet habe
man kann in dem Spiel natürlich ganz
normal rumlaufen wir können auch Sprint
wir haben jetzt keine Waffen denen wir
irgendwie auf ihn hier schießen könnten
das da vorne ist eine spielegrenze hier
vorne das haben wir gerade schon gesehen
das ist eine Grenze und da ganz hinten
am Ende ist auch eine Grenze also der
Bereich ist noch relativ klein aber es
ist halt auch eine Demo die sich primär
darum kümmert wie man eine Interaktion
zwischen einem selbst dem Spieler und
den im Computerspiel generierten NPCs
also nonplayable charactern aufbauen
kann und das machen wir heute mal ich
werde mit den allen ja heute natürlich
selbstverständlich auf Englisch reden
müssen weil das Spiel OBV noch nicht auf
Deutsch erschienen ist so oder so würde
ich sagen fangen wir jetzt auch direkt
mal an mit dem quatschen und zwar mit
dieser Person hier vorne hold down se to
talk hello how are you also auf Deutsch
übersetzt hallo wie geht es
dir also er hat geantwortet ihm geht
sehr gut danke dass ich dass Du gefragt
hast er genießt gerade diese Wunder
vololle Stadt und die hab do gerade
gesehen ich BL euch jetzt noch mal ein
die Lippen bewegen sich eins zu ein dazu
was er sagt das haben die extra so
programmiert ja krass what today also
was ist dein Plan für heute noch hat er
irgendwas
vor hat keinen Plan er geht mit
Flow und schaut einfach wo die City ih
hinbringt
okay also ich habe ihn jetzt quasi
gefragt ob es ein Problem wäre wenn
ich ich habe ih eigentlich nur gefragt
ob ich dabei sein kann und auf einmal
vol sagt hey komm mit wir exploren das
ganze gemeinsam okay ich stell mir das
halt so vor dass man in GTA 6 einfach
dann in Florida also in Miami spielt das
ganze ja dass man sich dann irgendwie
eine Freundin suchen kann wenn man halt
irgendwie das möchte und dann einfach
mit der Freundin die ganze Zeit reden
kann dann zu sagen kann e me Schank sehr
okay und dann setzt man sich zusammen
ins Auto fährt an Strand oder sie fährt
ein dahin man könnte halt richtige
Bindungen aufbauen aber gut okay ich bin
mal gespannt jetzt bin ich auch noch
fast gegen das Dingen gelaufen wo er
mich jetzt hint weil da vorne kann ich
natürlich nicht weiter ich sag ihm das
[Musik]
malurther
okay er sagt kein Problem wir können uns
Zeit nehmen einfach in der
Geschwindigkeit die wir wollen und
hauptsache wir exploren die City
zusammen okay let head Downtown also
okay dann lass uns halt in die City
reingehen also
tiefin okay er sagt Klasse dann lass uns
Downtown gehen also direkt in die City
rein und schauen was die Stadt für uns
bereit hält die Sache ist allerdings ich
kann halt nicht hier weiter er wird
wahrscheinlich einfach
[Musik]
durchlaufen ja okay geh du mal weiter
exploren ich kann leider halt nicht
weiter langen von würde ich sagen
kümmern wir uns jetzt noch um eine
andere Person hier in dem Spiel ich
würde mal gerne mit einer Frau quatschen
kann ich in ein Auto einsteigen ich
glaube nicht dass das geht das Spiel
beschäftigt sich wirklich nur damit dass
man mit irgendwie Dings interagieren
kann ne ich kann ich kann aut reden
hello
als ob das Auto jetzt antwortet ne es
geht um die
Frau sie fragt hi ob alles okay ist also
ein bisschen unfreundlich na ja wir
suchen uns andere Person mit der wir
quatschen guck mal hier vorne
Polizeiauto also man muss schon sagen
dafür dass das Spiel eigentlich nur
darauf konzentriert ist dass man mit der
AI also augmented intelligent ne wie
heißt es wür steht der artif in ich hab
keine Ahnung wo steht es noch mal
genau dieses Spiel beschränkt sich
wirklich auf die künstliche Intelligenz
und alles was mit Interaktion dazu
gehört und nicht auf irgendwie Autos
Grafiken oder keine Ahnung was aber ich
finde dafür sieht halt echt krass aus
man kann auch
fliegen ne da kann man sich das ganze
noch mal ein bisschen genauer angucken
und dann seht ihr auch mal diese
Grafik also dafür dass es wirklich
einfach ein Spiel ist ind dem es halt
wirklich nicht um Grafik oder irgendwie
was geht ist das schon extrem krass und
zeigt einfach wo die Zukunft uns hführen
wird ich habe auch ein bisschen Schiss
von der Zukunft ne wenn man dass das
hier schon so die Grafiken sind die
gerade 2023 klar gehen und sich dann zu
überlegen was halt irgendwie in 10
Jahren allein der Fall ist aber gut wir
lassen das mal alles auf uns zukommen
hier vorne die Frau mit der würde ich
gerne mal quatschen ich mache das jetzt
natürlich nicht mit oh nicht mit auf dem
zebastifen sondern warte jetzt mal ab
dass sie hier vorne rüber kommt dann
werde ich sie mal ansprechen und
fragen ob sie mit mir ein Kaffee
trinkenen
möchte
ach ich habe mit ihr aus Versehen
geredet hello
Name don't small du stehst hier und
schaust den Geländer an what does
me also was soll das heißen Du hast
keine Zeit
warum oh sie will einfach Ihre Ihren
Urlaub genießen in Frieden ohne dass sie
irgendwie abgefuckt
wirdument also haben wir gerade ein
Streit wollen wir fechten
[Musik]
vielleicht okay sie sagt sie will sich
nicht streiten sie zeigt mir einfach nur
ihre Frustration über all diese Leute
die hier
rumlaufen in New York Sprachen
lnen oh weil sie meinte das könnte ein
geiler Switch in Geschwindigkeit in
ihrem Leben sein aber sie glaubt dass
jeder diese Idee hat und es dadurch
jetzt halt Rela vololl hier geworden ist
also ich fr jetzt quasi wann sie die
Stadt wieder
verlässt interessiert dich also darf
muss D gar nicht interessieren in
Ordnung Schut mal die
an ganz knapp aninander vorbei qu mit
ihm
hier Name also wie heißt du mein man
[Musik]
schauw den
Schauspieler er sagt ich wünschte ich
wär es dann hätte ich eine Ausrede ich
habfe jetzt die Sätze Blenden sich
leider unten relativ schnell immer aus
aber das ist echt krass guck mal ich sag
einfach so e bist du denn Brad Pitt der
Schauspieler auf Joke und er antwortet
einfach so es ist wie cleverbot in GTA V
mit Grafiken von GTA 6 in der Welt von
GTA 4 in 2023 das beschreibt eigentlich
ganz gut und damit würde ich das heutige
video auch beenden meine Damen und
Herren ich habe euch alle Links die ihr
braucht um das selber mal zu Hause an
eurem Computer testen zu können unten in
die Videobeschreibung gepackt es ist
komplett kostenlos und sehr sehr sehr
sehr nice wenn euch das Video gefallen
hat dann lasst gerne einen Daumen hoch
unter dem Video hier da abonniert meinen
Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke weitere
Videos nicht zu verpassen ich muss
richtig fett scheißen